hey hey are you today we're playing
something exclusive if you're watching
this right now you're the only one where
they were the only ones that gets to
play this it's called little nightmare
it's a horror game you may have seen it
it looks very cool very very cool I'm
very excited about this title and I'm
also very happy that we got a chance to
play this sneak peek you know Bandai
Namco's thank you so much
Namco Bandai Namco thank you so much the
demo is supposed to be pretty harsh
pretty short so I'm not gonna try and
drag this out to be a 10-minute video
that would not be cool of me to do let's
begin playing oh boy am I excited that
sounded sarcastic but I I mean it I'm
very oh and here we are at the start
menu Hey look at that that looks like a
giant
skoshe dean whatever that's called
English okay all right this is the
horror game so hold your horses
this is [ __ ] awful so far thank you
so much for watching here we go tarz
your studios hey I don't think I played
anything from them before if you don't
know so far what to expect
don't worry it's about to begin here we
go and here we are you play as this
little girl this is really cool so it's
supposed to be kind of Tim Burton nice
style if that makes sense
hold to grab this is so cool what are
these little mushroom people I can jump
around Hey look at that okay I'm
guessing we need this to get up on
something this is freaky
who are we little yellow Riding Hood I
guess I don't know come on
I like the music
oh there's 30 okay climb oops
hahaha hey hey I got a bar anyone want
to play with me yeah nailed it can I
throw it
oh hell yeah I threw it on myself
no come back oh I got got a shoe got a
shoe everyone shoot I'll hit my own head
okay let's focus on what we're doing
very interesting I guess I don't really
need that thing maybe there's something
on the bed let's check it out if I can
get up here okay I can can I jump on the
bed
I can't fantastic whoop whoop whoop
whoop that painting is so creepy
okay I think my goal is to go up here so
I'm just gonna do that I'm a very good
climber everyone this whole room looks
like it was made from nightmares
seriously ah I got a I got this [ __ ] you
oh hell yeah
[ __ ] you can I claim no I can't then how
do I make this jump maybe I go for the
light oh that would have been cool wait
it's the whole room moving I think it is
that's creepy man okay well I'm going
here ouch ow [ __ ] me that hurt I suppose
we just need okay I'm an idiot we just
need to go to the door my bad
alright
Aaron
good little briefcase hi here we go hey
and we make it through the darkness Oh
God
lighter oh this is creepy let's take it
nice and slow hello champ
they're about my size good chin good
[ __ ] [ __ ] my light went out
well well well what do we have here this
is so pretty I love the art design I
guess I'll go in this super creepy
elevator yeah my knight why the [ __ ] not
tea set
I feel like this girl might be what is
really you should be looking at
we're sneaking we're sneaking okay we're
in the toilet
fantastic okay we got a sneak now what
the [ __ ] are we sneaking from oh ah
that's disgusting
humongous Oh
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh my god go go go now he sees
me
oh no oh god that's the Scott oh thank
God I thought it was gonna eat me or
some [ __ ] Jesus Christ did I did I
scream [ __ ] it's fine
hey hold on it's fine it's the first
time I played the game alright calm down
well I didn't really go that well oh she
just wakes up [ __ ] me I thought I was
being careful and [ __ ] oh we got to hide
in the dark is that a fish Jesus he's
cooking up something real good ah [ __ ]
[ __ ]
don't look underneath the table you just
needed that sausage okay we're good to
go back in action baby back in action
not a problem name is probably Emma's
answer okay
okay where we go we're go hit [ __ ] [ __ ]
and we're through not up hey it's the
mushroom people wait sprint that gave me
goose bumps man [ __ ] [ __ ] man ah Jesus
Christ man [ __ ] [ __ ] man [ __ ] chef
I keep oh oh okay [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
you sound like a [ __ ] elephant
like ice custom disgusting sorry okay a
better bet better babe baby babe flavor
do ooh a but about that but that bad bad
I'm just nicking man oh [ __ ]
Park okay look at this is our moment
this is our chance ha kodesh buckety
bucka bucka bucka sorry fishing i boats
how you doing I'm all right
I'm er I'm a new god oh boy oh boy just
gonna go in here just chillin out maxin
relaxin oh god oh god don't look in down
there
he's just gettin some salt he looks like
a salty [ __ ] what is he doing
what are you doing over there buddy
oh oh oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah that's
right put it back
[ __ ] off
[Music]
we're going and we wrap me my and my
yellow [ __ ] this is getting the
hell out of here Oh God we're gonna have
to climb up there run run
right go oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] me that's right [ __ ] what are you
gonna do now [ __ ] you
hey okay [ __ ] haha say another
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh okay better huh
[ __ ] just grab it [ __ ] my [ __ ] [ __ ] my
bag [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
Oh going up going up everybody Jesus
Christ [ __ ] that guy and his cake why
did I say cake he's obviously making a
beef something don't think it's vegan I
don't they are [ __ ] yeah you're my best
friend piece of ham oh maybe this is
actually a puzzle
yeah it seems like it well look at me
solving puzzles without even trying how
about that there you go a little meat
boy put you right there good good just
need one more one more lemme know can i
maybe No hey hey hey
why does he want to get us anyway like
there's any hardly any meat honest okay
we're basically Taylor Swift level here
okay maybe I just need to jump on it
maybe that's it give it a little extra
squish no no no one well [ __ ] me I don't
[ __ ] know it
well I thought I had the puzzle guys but
I I guess in reality I'm just a [ __ ]
idiot isn't it alright why would I want
what am I doing with this this is
clearly something to do with these maybe
I'm supposed to get something from here
oh boy that actually makes sense [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] got [ __ ] damage [ __ ] here
we go here we go here we go oh boy oh
boy we did that now we just got to do
this oh I love making some meat some
sausages 10 out of 10 vegans recommend
this game huh hey I made myself a bridge
ah [ __ ] I forgot to grab it [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] don't
panic pills I know you have a tendency
of panicking [ __ ] [ __ ] panic yeah okay
alright alright I get it
I'm in trouble alright here we go got
all the time in the world oh boy oh god
damnit jeez
what happened what happened oh I hit
space hello
sorry alright we cool
Moran all right looks like Brenda
cleared how about that great we get to
play more aah
reminds me a bit of my inside you feel
me you feelin me
yeah there's our tiny little shoots [ __ ]
you tight Oh what the [ __ ] is this are
the shoes hey are these shoes they're
shoe something shoe shoes the malarious
thank you very much why are the shoes
coming down here nah come on no I want
to play more that was very cool all
right so little nightmares everyone very
cool glad I got to play it like I said I
want to play more that's a shame I like
it's a very different take on what we've
previously seen in horror at least as of
late so yeah count me intrigued what do
you bros think let me know thank you so
much for watching
look I played a game guys and it was
actually good how about that maybe was
worth the wait
okay Alice that's all for me for now and
as always stay awesome press
[Music]